[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 hebdo au cours
de la prochaine demi heure nous allons
faire le point sur l'actualité locale
voici les titres en images de ce
vendredi 10 mai trente quatre listes
engagées dans la campagne des
européennes un record nous évoquons dans
un instant les deux semaines de campagne
restantes et nous verrons aussi que
plusieurs yvelinoise yvelinois sont
présents sur les listes
le conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines se tenait hier
soir au programme notamment l'avenir des
zones commerciales sur les secteurs de
coignières et de maurepas le début du
ramadan commémoration du 8 mai 45
biennale d'architecturé versailles nous
ferons aussi enfin d'édition le point
sur l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine
il y aura donc 34 liste en france pour
le scrutin européen du dimanche 26 mai
la 34e vient tout juste d'être validée
nicolas landry bonjour bonjour wilfried
et donc il y aura 34 east effectivement
ou le fruit d une 34e listes validées ce
vendredi 10 mai par le ministère de
l'intérieur après un avis favorable du
conseil d'état son nom une europe au
service des peuples une candidature
issue de l'union des démocrates
musulmans français
on aura donc 34 lits c'est un record il
faut revenir en 1999 dernier scrutin
comparable avec une cire qui seront
circonscription unique comme cette année
à vingt listes avaient été comptées et
la diversité est de mise bas aux côtés
des partis politiques classiques sont en
effet en lice des formations bien plus
petites qui sont parvenus à présenter
des listes paritaires de 79 personnes
fédéraliste défenseur du fric site
animalistes écologie sociaux-libéraux
identitaire et même royalistes et puis
on dénombre trois listes de gillet
jeunes les représentants du mouvement
nous pas réussi à se mettre d'accord sur
une seule tête de liste de nombreux
candidats de nombreuses candidates et
pour autant la participation s'annonce
faible
c'est classique une élection européenne
ne n'attire pas les électeurs une et pas
seulement pour la france mais aussi
partout en europe qu'on retrouve ce
phénomène en cause de la méconnaissance
des institutions et l'incompréhension
des mesures prises quand les premières
élections européennes se sont tenues en
1979 le taux de participation avait
atteint 78 71 %
dès les suivantes en 1984 56 22 72 % du
corps électoral s'était déplacée vers
les urnes
un chiffre qui passe à 50 % en 1989
jusqu'à 42 43 % en 2014 pour cette année
dans les sondages prévoient 40 voire 30
9 % de votants revenons sur un plan plus
local cette fois ci y at il des eyzies
blinoise et des yvelinois qui sont
engagés dans cette campagne
alors il ya des têtes de listes connues
françois xavier
belani le candidat des républicains est
élu à versailles
on se souvient qu'il a échoué de peu sur
la première circonscription pardon il ya
deux ans lors des élections législatives
benoît hamon ancien élu ps de trappes
ancien député de la 11e circonscription
images
il mène aujourd'hui la liste de son
nouveau parti génération point s sur les
autres listes on trouve aussi des
représentants locaux
le rassemblement national par exemple
présente en 22e place mathilde andraud
et la chef de file du parti dans les
yvelines
le maire de mantes la ville sur une
natte et lui 69e moins connu du côté de
lutte ouvrière on retrouve aussi en
deuxième place jean pierre mercier
le délégué cgt de l'usiné peugeot de
poissy porte-parole pendant la campagne
des présidentielles pour lutte ouvrière
et nous verrons donc ira siéger au
parlement le 26 mai en attendant que
disent les sondages à quinze jours
maintenant du scrutin globalement les
listes lrmr elle se talonnent elles sont
toutes deux à 22% d'intentions de vote
suivi par les républicains à 13 14 voire
même 15 2 selon les sondages la france
est soumise à 9 5% europe ecologie les
verts à 7% place publique parti
socialiste à 5%
là c'est pareil ça dépend des sondages
pour toutes ces formations politiques à
quelques demi pourcent exactement et les
autres ne totaliserait pas assez de voix
pour obtenir des élus debout la france
serait à 3,5 pour cent tout juste assez
pour obtenir un remboursement des frais
de campagne
merci nicolas et puis je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez suivre cette campagne
des européennes candidats en jeu
puis sur le terrain également avec les
candidats lorsqu'ils se rendent dans
notre département avec l'intégralité de
nos reportages et émissions avoir en
replay sur notre site internet merci
encore jeudi soir se tenait le conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi les
points à l'ordre du jour l'avenir des
zones commerciales de maurepas de
coignières de paris ouest aux portes de
chevreuse en passant par le forum du
gibet le deuxième pôle commercial saint
quentinois a doit penser à son évolution
et un cabinet d'étude a été mandaté pour
prévoir des pistes permettant de
revitaliser cette zone en lien avec les
acteurs économiques présents et puis la
population on va également faire une
étude de clientèle et de comportements
d'achat qui va démarrer dans les jours
prochains
donc un cabinet venir sur place
interrogé les consommateurs mais aussi
les directeurs d'ems saigne et les
directs et les propriétaires de locaux
pour connaître un peu leurs ambitions
leurs avis sur la totalité de la zone se
c'est vrai qu'on a paris ouest
le forum du jb les portes de chevreuse
est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit une même
et unique entité
par exemple est ce que dans l'esprit du
consommateur ils vont plutôt à paris
ouest
est ce qu'ils faisaient quand ils sont
en porte de chevreuse skis sont aussi à
paris ouest pour eux voyez il ya tout ça
à imaginer également dans une identité
forte
mais aussi de travailler sur l'offre
commerciale en même temps qu'on
travaille en parallèle les accès les
mobilités du futur et le logement afin
de renforcer les liens avec le
territoire saint quentinois lors de ce
conseil une subvention de 100 mille
euros pour l'école d'ingénieurs l'estaca
et une subvention de 40 mille euros pour
l'école d'audiovisuel les troisièmes ont
également été votés de délibération qui
n'ont pas fait l'unanimité auprès de
l'opposition
dans le reste de l'actualité politique
locale c'est ce dimanche matin que
guyancourt connaîtra le nom de son
nouveau maire le troisième depuis le
début du mandat après la démission de
françois de ligne et pour préparer
l'avenir
celle de marie christine le tarnec pour
des raisons de santé
le conseil municipal va se retrouver
pour désigner celui et qui revêtira
l'écharpé tricolore cette semaine pour
notre rubrique ça s'est passé retour en
2016 alors justement de l'arrivée à la
tête de cette ville de guyancourt demain
et christine le tarnec
[Musique]
26 voix pour 4 blanc et 2 contres
marie-christine le tarnec est depuis
mardi 15 novembre la nouvelle maire
socialiste de guyancourt l'ancienne élue
en charge notamment des finances succède
à françois de ligne et qu'ils avaient
décidé début octobre de passer le relais
après 14 ans à la tête de la commune ému
au moment de prendre la parole françois
de ligne et restera tout de même
conseiller municipal et communautaire
jusqu'en 2020 mes premiers mots c'est
pour dire que j'ai effectivement
beaucoup d'émotion c'est un passage de
relais
un passage de relais qui se passe bien
comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez ma
christine mènera le projet de ville avec
une équipe dynamique je serai jusqu'à
2020 dans cette équipe et c'est donc
avec beaucoup de sérénité que je peux
participer à a c'est moi qui sont et ses
amis qui sont devant nous pour
l'occasion benoît hamon député ps et
catherine tasca sénatrice socialiste
avait fait le déplacement plus d'une
centaine d'habitants également des
habitants que la nouvelle maire a tenu à
rassurer son mandat sera celui de la
continuité
j'ai été élu sur une liste depuis 2014
donc maintenant je suis maire
effectivement au milieu du mandat mais
j'ai participé à la liste de françois de
ligne et on a été élu pour un mandat
effectivement de 6 ans avec un projet de
ville et je vais respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris devant les
aigles ans pour toi et on va les tenir
l'opposition municipale elle a tenu à
saluer l'engagement de françois de ligne
et durant 14 ans l'élection d'un nouveau
maire signifie également de nouvelles
relations avec la majorité
c'est évident que cette démission doit
aussi nous permettre de relancer de
relancer les échanges de relancer les
discussions avec avec l'exécutif
je proposerai à marie-christine le
tarnec peut-être de se voir afin de
pouvoir discuter en effet 2
et bien des quatre années qui qui
viendront jusqu'en 2020 marie-christine
le tarnec le devra également composer
avec quelques remous au sein de sa
majorité municipale les quatre élus
écologistes n'ont ainsi pas pris part au
vote lors de son élection
[Musique]
nous passons résumé de la semaine à
présent avec tout d'abord l'ouverture du
mois de ramadan lundi le jeune a débuté
pour environ 140 mille personnes de
confession musulmane dans les yvelines
et grégory et canale a reçu à cette
occasion abdelaziz el jaouhari président
du cemi le centre d'études et
d'initiatives musulmane des yvelines
premièrement c'est un des cinq piliers
de l'islam donc c'est vraiment une idée
d adoration fondamental pour la
communauté de croyants ajoutez à cela
donc s'est doublée d'un comment dire
d'un vrai travail de générosité pendant
ce mois donc c'est un mois où nous le
constatons tous nos lieux de culte qui a
un regain de la pratique religieuse
donc il ya déjà le jeune en lui même
mais c'est aussi nos espaces de prière
nos mosquées une salle de prière connaît
une activité très intense sur moi si
vous avez un rôle on l'a dit
d'observatoire dans les yvelines alors
vous dénombré 140 mille personnes
environ de confession musulmane dans le
département soit 10% de la population
quel est votre rôle alors pendant 7o du
ramadan vous disiez il ya ce rôle de
distribution des repas d'accompagnement
le rôle du ce et michael et il en fait
on travaille justement sur la présence
musulmane au sein d evelyne est tout
simplement deux à la fois d'avoir une
comment dire deux des données qui soient
fiables
je pense que c'est important et pour la
communauté musulmane mais portent nos
partenaires publics ou privés d'ailleurs
et pour la communauté elle-même et
deuxièmement c'est qu'il ya un certain
nombre de deux comment dire de besoin et
qu'il faut remonter donc ça peut être
sur la question des lieux de culte ça
peut être sur les carrés confessionnels
dans les cimetières
ça peut être sur les besoins de
solidarité où on en a parlé donc voilà
donc c'est vraiment de se doter d'un
certain nombre de deux relevés de
terrain pour accompagner au mieux et
dans la sérénité la communauté mais
aussi et pas que la communauté s'est
tous nos partenaires publics privés
les autres communautés religieuses le 8
mai nous avons commémorer le soixante
quatorzième anniversaire de la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale et cette
histoire nationale refuse rejoint bardon
de l'histoire locale point stratégique
en raison de son chemin de fer trap a en
effet souffert pendant la guerre les
bombardements alliés détruisant ait les
deux tiers de la ville nous avons
rencontré eli robin cette semaine
habitants de la commune et il se
souvient de cette période qu'elle de
souvenirs vous gardez de cette période
d'occupation par l'allemagne certaine
peur parce que j'allais à versailles à
l'école à versailles et à jules ferry
est sûr que l'on rencontre sur la route
dans les trains outre des les allemands
officiellement ou pas et il fallait
quand même pas trop déroger aux règles
pourront par contre à l'école
jules-ferry à versailles
on se sentait relativement libre femmes
je peux même dire que mon prof
d'allemand et elle n'a jamais usé de de
la victoire allemande pour nous faire
des cures le terme cieux très gentil
vous disiez vous étiez à l'école à à
versailles vous êtes resté pendant sept
heures de la guerre dans cette ville de
trappes la ville de trappes qui a
particulièrement pertinent ce faire il
ya eu un bombardement en 1944 juste
avant le débarquement quelques quelques
jours avant le débarquement du 6 juin
oui il ya trois bombardements et le 6
mars qui est extrêmement important bien
sûr sa visée le transport la gare de
trappes et le transport du matériel au
triage de trappes militaire c'était le
premier le 6 mars le deuxième c'est et
le 1er juin et le troisième c'était le 3
juin
mais entre temps il y avait souvent de
trois avions anglais ou américains qui
passait qui file un coup mais trois gros
bombardements ca c'est à ces dates là
c'était une cité cheminote à l'époque
trap est ce qu'il y avait une fibre
résistante parmi ces cheminots bah oui
oui je oui et j'avais même des déportés
et l'intégralité de cet entretien est à
voir en replay sur notre site internet
l'actualité de la semaine c'est aussi à
l'hommage rendu par le département mardi
à ces soldats du feu 57 d'entre eux ont
reçu une médaille pour avoir combattu
l'incendié de notre dame de paris et
puis lutte est également l contre la
fuite de pétrole à auteuil est et boissy
sans avoir le reportage d'honneur et
diront ce pardon et nicolas landry des
sapeurs-pompiers blinois distingués pour
leurs récentes actions notamment pour
avoir aidé à sauver le beffroi nord de
notre dame de paris
il y a quelques années le conseil
départemental des yvelines avait fait
l'acquisition de deux bras élévateur de
46 mètres de haut
une aide précieuse le 15 avril dernier
dans la capitale dire notre fierté
et dire aux yvelinois peut être fier
votre argent a été bien utilisé
ça a coûté par yvelinois 70 centimes
d'euro
voyez cet argent
heureusement qu'on a dépensé 57
sapeurs-pompiers vinon ont reçu une
médaille
c'est le cas de la dudh ans steve venot
il est resté plus de sept heures dans
une nacelle pour lutter contre
l'incendié de notre dame de paris
on a eu une action plus qu'efficace
ce soir là donc on est assez fiers ces
jardins revenus parce que dans une
carrière de pompier je pense que on
frappe à l'intervention majeur aussi
importante
assez souvent on est fière aussi d'avoir
préservé
cette structure ce bâtiment car ça fait
partie de notre histoire c'est un peu
demain imaginer versailles son château
on n'imagine pas lors de cette cérémonie
un hommage a également été rendu aux
sapeurs pompiers mobilisés le 25 février
dernier lors de la rupture du pipeline à
auteuil et boissy sans avoir moi j'ai
été engagé l'après midi
effectivement pour coordonner les
opérations de pompage
suite à la rupture du 'pipeline' ça fait
40 ans je suis sapeur pompier c'est la
première fois que j'intervenais sur une
rupture de bail très fier pour le centre
de secours
et puis très fier pour
à titre personnel la science c'est
toujours une fierté de recevoir une
médaille
au total près de 4000 personnes au sein
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours oeuvre au quotidien pour la
sécurité des yvelinois
souhaitez-vous le maintien de la prison
en centre-ville c'est la question posée
par poissy à ses habitants la ville a
lancé jeudi une consultation citoyenne
sur la maison centrale ce sera du 1er au
16 juin à fin mars
souvenez vous une partie du mur
d'enceinte extérieur esce effondrés
relançant le débat sur la vétusté du
site michael ennemis dans la prison de
poissy sera t-elle déplacer une
consultation citoyenne numérique va être
lancée le samedi 1er juin par la mairie
pour connaître l'avis des habitants une
décision qui fait écho à l'effondrement
survenu le 28 mars dernier d'une partie
du mur d'enceinte de la prison notre
prison est édifié ici depuis 18 ans 21
ça fait presque 200 ans
je ne parle même pas auparavant que le
couvent des ursulines dans les années
750 elle a l'âge de ses artères et elle
est de plus en plus dangereuse pour les
administrés ne sont pas à l'abri d'un
mur qui s'écroule
nous souhaitons aller plus loin je
souhaite consulter les pisciacais pour
savoir si comme nous ils souhaitent ou
non le maintien de la maison centrale en
centre ville pour donner leur avis les
habitants de la commune devront
télécharger une application sur leur
smartphone ou leur tablette
le dispositif sera également accessible
dans les maisons de quartier le vote
sera quant à lui anonyme est unique on y
aura trois réponses possibles
oui non ou votre blanc et nous avons
fait appel à un organisme sécurisé
proposé par notre part entre partenaires
orange pour pouvoir rassembler
l'ensemble des vols en toute
confidentialité clic une personne qui
puisse voter à la fois évidemment les
résultats sont dévoilés le dimanche 7
juin à partir de 11 heures en mairie
sont transmis au ministère de la justice
gestionnaire de la prison il est évident
que si les pisciacais et les pisciacais
aller dans le sens d'un nom maintient
donc d'un transfert de la prison
ailleurs que dans centre-ville ça ne
donnerait plus de poids et je perds de
pression mais plus de poids plus
d'arguments encore pour valider ce que
nous souhaitons depuis des années si
possible
selon l'élu le déplacement de la prison
sur un autre secteur de la ville
coûterait près de 80 millions d'euros
contre 60 millions pour une rénovation
promise par l'état pour la remplacer
différents projets sont à l'étude comme
un musée ou des espaces verts nous
passons l'actualité culturelle et la
première biennale d'architecturé
versailles architecture et paysage se
poursuit expositions manifestations vont
rythmer l'événement jusqu'au 13 juillet
dans plusieurs lieux de la ville le
potager du roi par exemple a ouvert ses
portes
aurélie rose très jolie ainsi très grand
9 hectares de fruits de légumes ou
encore d'herbes aromatiques
situé en plein coeur du centre
historique de versailles le potager du
roi été construit par jean baptiste de
la quintinie à la demande du roi louis
xiv qui était féru de jardinage
il est classé monument historique et
jardins remarquables
j'imagine et pas que ce soit aussi grand
c'est assez respectueux je trouve ça
garder quand même l'esprit naturel et
puis bah on va c'est sympa qui est des
petits bancs des petites chaises c'est
un lieu que j'aime bien où je viens
parfois acheter des légumes parce qu'ils
produisent aussi des légumes
et puis c'est quand même nos ancêtres
qui ont mis ce potager au point
habituellement fermés au public ce lieu
confidentiel ouvre gratuitement ses
portes à l'occasion d' esprit jardin
cette année le potager du roi fait
également partie de la programmation de
la première biennale d'architecturé de
paysage de versailles
l'idée c'est de mettre en valeur la
relation entre la ville et la production
alimentaire
la villa doit être pour exister
alimenter alimenter que ce soit en
produits alimentaires mais aussi en
idées en construction en énergie et donc
c'est ça quand on essaie de mettre en
valeur aujourd'hui ici avec le temps
capricieux vous n'avez pas pu tout
découvrir sur la production de ses
fruits et légumes qui firent la renommée
de la table du roi soleil
sachez que jusqu'à mi juillet plusieurs
visites sont organisées
la biennale d'architecturé qui
s'articule autour de trois grandes
thématiques ayant chacune sa journée
dédiée la ville créative la ville
résiliente et la ville fertile en dehors
des débats de nombreuses expositions
sont aussi à visiter à parmi lesquels
versailles architecture rêver 760 1815
qui présente un rassemblent
inédit de projets d'architecturé élaboré
entre les 16e et 19e siècles pour le
château et ses jardins programme complet
de la manifestation sur back bay ap
tirer idf.com une autre idée de sortie
culturelle à présent pour ce week end le
village des futurs insolite le 11 mai à
la commanderie à elancourt les saint
quentinois auteur d'une invention pour
on l'a présenté au public écoute et
flora tout est responsable de l'atelier
est des sciences elle était l'invitée du
7-8 loisirs cette semaine pour la
première fois à la commanderie nous
organisons donc le village des futurs
insolite
donc il réunit à la fois des
associations des start up des
particuliers des inventeurs bien sûr
mais également des artistes qui
présenteront des inventions aussi des
objets fabriqués
le but est de valoriser les talents la
créativité l'ingéniosité l'inventivité
de montrer qu'à tout âge et dans tous
les domaines on peut être acteurs de
l'innovation et des inventions donc pour
cela nous proposons à samedi prochain à
la commanderie
différentes animations donc il y aura
des stands avec des manipulations des
expériences des rencontres vraiment des
start up des associations fait pour tous
les âges ça va des enfants qu'une
conférence pour les adultes voilà tout à
fait donc des trois ans vous pourrez
avec vos enfants manipuler des objets
pour inventer les objets du futur voir
l'habitat du futur avec le musée de la
ville mais également participer à des
ateliers autour de l'art duino donc des
cartes programmables avec planète
sciences
regardez des robots classé des atomes
vous pourrez également vraiment aller à
la rencontre d'inventeurs médaillés de
grand salon vous pourrez aussi piloté
une oeuvre par la pensée avec ma flowers
de loisirs toujours pour continuer cette
édition et direction vélizy 2 qui a
connu ces derniers mois quelques
changements le centre commercial
yvelinois a vu arriver un nouveau cinéma
est un espace entièrement repensé dédié
à la restauration et aux loisirs une
extension de 20 mille mètres carrés dont
les contours nous sont présentés par
michael ennemis dans la nouvelle
extension de vélizy 2 est terminé après
l'ouverture début mars de son nouveau
cinéma le centre commercial a inauguré
quelques jours plus tard une halte
gourmande au total 23 restaurant pour
manger sur place ou sur le pouce se sont
implantés dans ce nouvel espace de 5000
m² il y avait de fortes attentes à notre
clientèle pour avoir plus d'hommes de
restauration c'était une demande depuis
des années parce qu'on a quand même 50
mille salariés qui travaillent ici tous
les jours à proximité donc le mili
forcément mais également le week-end
parce que nos pics d'activité sont le
samedi et maintenant le dimanche et on a
une clientèle qui souhaitent se
restaurer le midi le soir avant d'aller
au cinéma et on avait un besoin a besoin
important on avait dix sept points de
restauration donc là on passe à 40
en parallèle de la restauration les
gérants mist également sur les loisirs
ici cette salle d'arcade en réalité
virtuelle propose de vous immerger dans
un monde 2.0 donc vous voyez derrière
moi mais les différentes stations
délimiter
chaque lion est équipé d'un casque et de
deux manettes reproduisant mouvement des
mains et et grâce à ça il va se plonger
dans le monde de son choix
seul ou à plusieurs donc ça peut être
simplement de l'exploration si vous
voulez visiter une ville dans le monde
n'importe où dans le monde
si vous voulez jouer à différentes
choses voulait faire de l' escalade sur
la baie d'halong au vietnam ou sur les
parois rocheuses des haltes dans des
paysages magnifiques vous pouvez pour
cette nouvelle extension les
propriétaires ont dû mettre près de 140
millions d'euros sur la table
au total plus de 300 emplois ont été
créés
[Musique]
la coupe du monde de football féminin se
déroulera en france cette année coup
d'envoi le 7 juin dans les yvelines
croissy sur seine accueille notamment
l'équipe de france nous y reviendrons
d'ailleurs dans notre dossier de la
rédaction dès la semaine prochaine mais
pour le moment coup d'oeil sur les
animations dans le reste de l'île de
france notamment
a montreuil un reportage le confrère
devient grand paris la coupe du monde de
football féminin c'est aussi pour les
plus jeunes une vingtaine de filles de 7
à 17 ans s'était donné rendez-vous à
montreuil licenciés ou non
chacune a pu jouer le ballon au pied il
ya tous les clubs de mon travail
aujourd'hui on a même une petite fille
de porto cobac est venue est également
s'est ouvert à tout le monde donc c'est
aussi une initiation pour pour
des petites filles qui souhaitent voir
ce que enfin connaître le football
au programme ateliers arbitrage
questionnaire sur les valeurs
républicaines ou encore ateliers éco
responsable mais l'activité principale
c'est bien le football dans les clubs
les groupes féminins voient leurs
effectifs augmenter d'année en année
pour les entraîneurs la coupe du monde
en france est aussi une opportunité pour
les plus jeunes on va essayer d'y
participer
il ya un stade en région parisienne à
travers plusieurs animations et
plusieurs dispositifs on espère avoir la
possibilité d'emmener nos joueuses au
stade et
et supporter l'équipe de france
supporter l'équipe de france féminine
une chose que les filles ne sont
patentes habitué à faire moi j'aime bien
le foot et je regarde jamais les filles
ça m'arrive quelquefois mais s'il ya des
matches qui passe à la télé tout va je
pense je vais regarder la fédération
compte près de 165 mille licenciées
féminines elles seront toutes derrière
les françaises à partir du 7 juin
prochain
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8
hebdo au retour de l'actualité locale
lundi à dès 18h en direct première
rediffusion à 19h et puis aussitôt en
replay sur notre site internet
très beau week end
[Musique]